Evet konuşmamızın başlığı a a en sonunda
söyleyeceğim ne demek
hepimizin hayatında 3 temel aşama var
birinci aşama bir açıdan hikaye dinleme
aşaması doğduk
hiçbir şey bilmiyoruz sürekli
etrafımızda Birileri bir şey anlatıyor
hikayeler anlatıyor Sonra yavaş yavaş
büyüyoruz
konuşmayı öğreniyoruz alfabeyi
öğreniyoruz ve ondan sonra hikaye
anlatmaya da başlıyoruz birinci aşama
hikaye dinleme aşaması ikinci aşama buna
eşlik eden hikaye anlatma aşaması sonra
da artık yaşam süremiz ne kadarsa
şansımız ne kadarsa
bu boyuta veda ediyoruz bu dünyadan
göçüp gidiyoruz 3 aşamada hikaye olma
aşaması farkındalık olarak seminerlerde
hep öz bilgi istiyorlardı hocam yaşamak
ne demek diye sorduklarında hikaye
dinleyip hikaye anlatırken hikaye
Olmaktır yaşamak demiştim Bu bağlamda da
hepinizin ve her Birinizin muhteşem
hikayeler olmanız dileklerimle başlamak
istiyorum
Deniz Dündar 1976 Tunceli doğumlu anne
çiçek Baba Abdullah 7 kardeş ortanca
Çocuğum çok mutlu bir çocukluk geçirdim
sonra yaşam serüvenim içerisinde en az 1
yıl ve üzerinde yaşadığım şehirler Rize
Elazığ Sakarya Ankara İstanbul San
Francisco Adrasan ve en son 28 Ekim
2021'de kendimi Fethiye'de buldum bir
arkadaşıma uğramıştım Bir iki gün vakit
geçireyim oradan San francisco'ya
döneyim diye öyle olmadı yürürken Şehit
Fethi Bey Parkı oradan bir yer gördüm
hipokampüs diyor Eşref hocam burada
mısınız
Evet
1492'de Coğrafi keşifler döneminde böyle
gemileri binip insanlar çılgınca
bilinmeyen okyanusa yerken açıyordu
Eşref hocam benim fethi ile tanıştığım
ilk gemicilerden
kovworking Space Cafe hipokampüs ya
dedim Burası ne güzel bir yer sonra
mutlu Bey ile tanıştım o da küçük bir
yer açmış sonra iklime bakıyorum San
francisco'dan daha güzel
İnsanlara bakıyorum daha güzel daha
misafirperver daha içten öyle düşünmeye
başladım birkaç gün 10 Kasım'da hemen
kayıt oldum dedim Vazgeçtim gitmiyorum
Bir aylığına üye
ve Sonrası zaten Eşref hoca ile dostluk
arkadaşlık diğer değerli dostlar Hicran
hanım Serbülent Bey İsmini şu an
unutacağım için ve kızacaklar ama Ozan
bey bir sürü güzel insan sonra Ercan
hocam Ercan hocam Ercan Altuğ Yılmaz
hocam burada tanıştık sonra hocam dedim
ben bir seminer yapalım mı Yapalım
seminerin ismini de san francisco'dan
san Fethiye'ye koyduk hipokampüs'te icra
ettik ve ondan sonra Hikayemiz başladı
Aralık
2021 Eşref Hocama şey demiştim Hocam biz
beraber güzel şeyler yapacağız Fethi
güzel bir yer 5 yıl içerisinde buraya 10
milyar dolar yatırım çekeceğiz
Fethiye'nin başına bir tane kelime
koyacağız San diyeceğiz üreteceğiz katma
değer yaratacağız yerel insanlarla
çalışacağız tanışacağız okullarla
yöneticilerle politikacılarla gençlerle
girişimcilerle O hayal doğrultusunda
çalışmalar yapıyoruz Ben bu vesileyle
Kendimi yeni bir Fethiyeli olarak kabul
edebilirim Bu 15 17 ay bilmiyorum ne
kadar oldu ama %80'i buradaydım
1 bölümde size kısa girişimcilik
hikayemi anlatacağım
başlayalım
tema Yarın da yaşamak Yarın da yaşamak
Ben sizi 2011 yılına götürüyorum ben
2011 yılında Yarın da yaşıyordum
Mecidiyeköy'de küçük bir ofis
üniversiteden ayrılmışım eski
akademisyenim Başkent Yeditepe bilgi
Üniversitesi'nde 9 yıl öğretim görevlisi
olarak çalıştım kendi hayallerimin
peşinden küçük bir araştırma merkezi
kurdum oradaki öğrencilerin de
çalışıyorum ya dedim Neden olmasın
arkadaşlar
hocamızın bahsettiği üzere I have a
dream modunda bir konuşma yaptım 2011
daha İnstagram yok YouTube çok daha
böyle bu kadar büyümemiş bayağı bir sürü
bir şey yok Türkiye'de Yemek Sepeti var
ama Yemek Sepeti batacak mı Çıkacak mı
Kolektif Hafız yok covercing Space yok
Tesla yok hiçbir şey yok 2011'deyiz
arkadaşlar dedim bir uygulama yapacağız
İngilizce öğrenme uygulaması kısa
videolar keseceğiz işte her alandan
videolar keseceğiz bunu işte
uygulamalara web'e uyarlayacağız
ücretsiz yapacağız eğitimde fırsat
eşitliğine katkı sağlayacağız sonra 1000
kişi 10.000 kişi 100 bin kişi
milyonlarca insan Dünyanın her
tarafından moscreen indirecek kullanacak
İngilizce öğrenme süreçlerinde hem
öğrencilere hem öğretmenlere bir destek
uygulaması yapacağız bunu yaparken de
Anadolu kültürüyle yapacağız Önce
dokunacağız insanlara Ondan sonra
kendisi zaten yolunu bulur yolda bir
sürü zorluk çekebilir hiç önemli değil
hocam Tamam şöyle yapalım böyle yapalım
sorular
yaptılar ettiler ve hikaye başladım ve
ilerledi o Fikri milyonlarca insana
ulaştı 2020 yılında böyle tıkandık
konuşmacılarımız Hayat hikayelerini
anlatırken herkesin tıkanma noktası var
2020'de çok tıkandık pandemi de var
artık böyle bir şey yapmam lazım ama
altyapısı çok güçlü olduğu için verilere
baktık En Son Nerede büyüyoruz Çin'den
bir buçuk iki milyon kullanıcı edinmişiz
o screen kendi kendine Çin'de yaklaşık 2
milyon kullanıcıya ulaşmış
kuraktivite Hayatımın her zaman önemli
parçası oldu Hemen Çin büyükelçi ile
temasa geçtik yazılı olarak dedik ki biz
böyle böyle bir iş yaptık Şu an Çin'de
insanlar kullanıyor Çin'de büyüme
potansiyelimiz çok yüksek elçilik olarak
bize Çin'den yatırımcıları işbirliği
yapabileceğimiz insanları
tanıştırırsanız Türk Çin ortaklığıyla
ortak bir girişim yapalım küreselleşmeyi
yani bu 8-10 milyon kullanıcıdan 100
milyon kullanıcıya gitme serüvenini
beraber yapalım Çok hoş karşıladılar
Peki dediler randevu tarihleri derken bu
kovid'in pandemi çıktı uhranda Ondan
sonra ertelendi ben de kendimi
Mecidiyeköy'de küçük bir evde buldum
kardeşimin evinde ben ölürüm kapalı bir
atasözü vardır evde kalan insan
ölür Yani ben evde kalamam hemen bir Üç
kağıt yaptık kardeşim fırıncıydı dedim
gel dedim İstanbul'a ekmek getir beni de
al beni de fırıncı yap Ondan sonra aldı
beni ben kaçtım adrasan'a gittim Adrasan
da tatlı bir dinlenme dönemi orada başka
üretimler ve bekleme süreci adresinden
sonraki kısımda San francisco'ya
gitmeden önce burada Buraya gelince
Fethiye yapacağız
çalışmalara başladık güzel çalışmalar
yaptık okullarda Seminerler vesaire bir
pazar günü belki de çalıştık sanırım TED
mentörlerinden biriyim acıktım şurada
paşa kebap var fethiyeler bilir gideyim
bir yemek yiyeyim dedim yemeğimi yerken
3 tane Çinli genç arkadaş
merhaba dedim Nasılsınız iyisiniz Ne
yapıyorsunuz
Tamam güzel hayatım çok merak ediyorum
bizim bir uygulamamız var şimdi dedi 2
milyon kullanıcımız var hiç Çin'in App
Store'da görmedim bir bakabilir misin
ismi ne ismini söyledim heceledim Lütfen
dedi hangisi dedi orada garip bir
şekilde bununla karşılaştık
Biz burada Sessiz sedasız yaşarken
Çin'de bir Çinli şirket teknoloji
şirketi Şangay merkezde o fikrini çok
sevmiş demiş biz de yapalım ama biz o
kadar çok sevmiş ki aynı isimimizi
kullanmış güzel renklerimizi
değiştirmemiş çok memnun oldum logomuzu
da değiştirmemiş ondan da çok memnuniyet
duydum biraz araştırma Tabi o Duygu çok
ilginç bir duygu yani Birden böyle
şaşırıyorsunuz
sonra bütünü okuduğunuz kitaplar
Seminerler hepsi birden geliyor ben bu
işe Nasıl bakacağım bu meseleye Nasıl
bakacağım orada biraz geyik yaptık Şimdi
arkadaşlarla
başarısı eğitimlerinde eğitmenlerin
genellikle yaptırdığı bir aktivite
vardır Burada da yapalım beraber herkes
lütfen parmağını yukarı kaldırıp saat
yönünde çevirir mi Saat yönü 1 2 3 4
şöyle bir çevirelim
O çok güzel bir görüntü çevirelim
çevirirken hareketi değiştirmeden yavaş
yavaş Elimizi aşağı indirelim hareketi
değiştirmeden İnsin İnsin şimdi şu
açıdan Bakın bakalım artık Saat yönünde
mi dönüyor yoksa saat yönünün tersinde
mi
Dolayısıyla dedim ki ben bu meseleye
şöyle bakacağım o screen kimim bizim
%100 yerli ve Türk bir şirket hikayesi
zaten uzun netflix dizisi oluyor
marka tescilli sorunu yok 2 milyondan
fazla dijital Delil var orijinal bir
eser olduğu için zaten sorun yok bu
screen yapmak kelime bu tanrının
Allah'ın bir lütfu dedim yani biz burada
yorulurken Sağ olsunlar
şimdi arkadaşlarımız böyle bir şey
yapmış elçiliğin Haberi olduğunu
zannetmiyorum hemen İstanbul'a gittim
avukatlarla Bir Görüş alışverişinde
bulunduk hemen Fahri konsolos'ta
randevuyu aldık 15 Aralık 2 ya da 3
Ocak'ta Çin başkonsolosluğuna gitti
ticari ateşeye 2020 ile hatırlattık
dedik ki biz böyle bir toplumumuz hiç
sorun değil yeter ki iyi niyet olsun bu
arkadaşlarla bizle tanıştırın beraber
oturalım kim ne suç işlemişse cezasını
ödesin Ondan sonra da yine aynı
fikirdeyiz beraber bir ortak girişim
kuralım Dilara ateşkesi sağ olsun iyi
karşıladı not aldı o Diplomasi süreçleri
uzun sürer
tabii
burada yapılan bir yanlış var bir de bir
platform ihlali var Çünkü bu uygulamanın
dağıtılmasını sağlayan platformlar Apple
ve Huawei apqalleri Dolayısıyla orayla
oradaki süreci de San Francisco tarzı
yapalım dedik Amerika'da genelde böyle
büyük şirketler büyük bir ihmal ve ihlal
yaptığında hemen önce ihmale uğrayan
kişiler Televizyon kanallarına gider
kamuoyuna duyurur ve avukatlarla bir
şekilde ya anlaşma masası kurulur tespit
edilir zarar ödeme yapılır ya da uzun
yasağı süreçler işte Facebook'ta
olmuştur böyle şeyler
Google earth’ün bir hikayesi vardır
filmini izleyenler vardır Çok güzel bir
filmdir Dolayısıyla kendimi çok iyi
hissettim dedim Artık tamamen San
Fethiye'ye odaklanabilirim Şimdi iki
şirketimiz var ne kadar para kazanıyoruz
bilmiyoruz kazandık da bilmiyoruz Çünkü
ücretsiz bir uygulama Şimdi şirket
ücretli bir uygulama Komik olan şey
geçen Çinli şirket uygulamasını böyle
deniyordum ücretsiz üyeliğiniz bitti
benden 1000 TL istedi böyle garip bir
duygu o screen Ben yaptım Benden 1000 TL
istiyor ödemedim dedim yeter bu kadar
diye
wosecik'in hikayesi nereye evrilir
bilemeyiz göreceğiz yaşayacağız Ama
ilginç bir hikaye bunu Fethiye'de bu
etkinlikleri sizlerle paylaşmış olayım
insan insanlığından beslenir diğer
projemizde
üniversitede bir projede gelecek
nesilleri nasıl yetiştiririz Ben böyle
biraz üniversite öğrencisi olmanın böyle
gençliğiyle hararetiyle şey yazmıştım
gelecek nesilleri asla yetiştiremeyiz
Çünkü sütün kalitesi yeterli değil sütun
kalitesi yeterli olmazsa istediğini
ustayı getir istediğin mayayı kullan
kaliteli peynir yoğurt falan yapamazsın
orada da yazmıştım süt mevcut
yetişkinler yani Bizler çocuklarımıza
Bela acılardan iyi örnek olamayan
eksiklerimiz olan yetişkinler uzun bir
liste ne lazım Türkler olarak bir sorun
tespitinde mahiriz becerikliyiz sorduğu
tespit ettik sosyalleştik sorunlar
üzerinden çözüm önerilerini ürettik
nerede zayıfız aksiyona geçmekte aksiyon
tarafında da şöyle bir şey yazmıştım
yetişkin öğrenmesi hamlesi Bunu sadece
çözebilecek tek şey yetişkin öğrenmesi
hamlesi hepimiz üniversitede bitirdik iş
hayatı aile hayatı zor o zaman Ne
yapalım diye O döneminde bir
uygulama başlattık işe aldığımız
arkadaşlara dedik ki; 8 saat mesela
yapacaksın uzmanlığınla ilgili şunu bunu
yapacaksın
tamamı Tamam hayır 7.5 yapacaksın Niye
yarım saat Yarım saat kitap okuyacaksın
kitabı bana desteklerini oku İş
saatlerinde Mesai saatlerinde mi Evet
Okuyup ne yapacağım başka insanların da
görmesini istediğiniz satırları insan
insandan beslenen veri tabanına at Biz
her yıl bir kitap çıkaralım bunu 2015'te
hayata geçirdik 16 17 18 devam ederken
sonra uygulama yayıldı Şu an başka
okullarda bunu yapıyor 5 büyük korkudan
biridir işini kaybetme korkusu
ve buradaki Vizyon 30 yıllık bir vizyon
düşünün işini kaybetmek korkusuyla kitap
okuyan birisi zorla kitap okutturulan
birisi Birkaç ay sonra zaten kitaplar
dünyasıyla tanışacak Ondan sonra keyifle
okuyacak Ondan sonra da anne babalar
çocuklarına kitap oku demeyecek çünkü
çocuklar anne ve babalarının kitap
okuduğunu zaten görecek gelirlerinde bir
stk'ya bağışladık Amazon'da satılıyor
insan insanlığından beslenir 1 2 3 diye
onation projesi bir Temel fıkrası
projesi Temel ile Dursun
konuşuyorlar dursun diyor ki temel iki
evin olursa birini bana verir misin
Tabii ki canın sağ olsun iki araban
Tabii ki ne demek iki tavuğun vermem
Niye Çünkü var şimdi İsyan ettiğim
şeylerden biri adaletsiz gelir dağılımı
piramitin tepesinde 100 kişi ya da
şirket 100 aşağıdaki 4 milyarla dünyadan
aynı Payı alıyor
Bu hiçbirimizin kabul edilebileceği bir
şey değil o yüzden yayılması lazım
dünyada birçok sorunun çözümü Parayla
alakalı paylaşımla alakalı daha çok
üretip daha çok paylaşmak lazım onda
böyle bir vicdan projesi San Francisco
derken yazmıştım Basit bir şeyi var işte
Ozan Bey burada Ozan Bey Zenginlik
sınırınız ne diyor ki 20 milyon dolar
olur milyon dolarım olursa ben kendimi
zengin kabul etmiş olacağım O zaman
diyoruz dijital dua geleceğe bir dua
gönder ben Ozan İlhan söz veriyorum 20
milyon dolarım olduktan sonra bireysel
zenginleşmeye hızımı yavaşlatacağım
Ondan sonra zengin olmaya devam edeceğim
tabii ki ama ondan sonra kazanacağım her
yüz birimin %49'unu dünyada gelişme
ihtiyaç duyulan alanlara ya da ihtiyaç
duyan insanlara kendi irademle
aktaracağım sözünü veriyor musunuz
veriyorsun o zaman bu söz ünü dünyaya
duyur yalnız gittin şimdi
11-12 tane projeden bir tanesi öne çıktı
Sea şimdi 2011'de anlattığım Vizyon ay
have Dream vardı Şimdi 2023'te
anlatıyorum biraz da ilerlemiş durumda
dünyanın en hızlı büyüyen Cover King
kafe zincirini kuruyoruz ama airbnb gibi
Uber gibi airbnb dünyanın en büyük oteli
ama bir tane odası yok
Uber dünyanın en büyük taksi şirketi ama
bir tane taksici yok Bizler bir Yönetim
bilişim teknoloji veri Finans şirketi
olarak ve insanlık tarihinde bu rekor
starbucks'dadır 30 yılda 38 bin
şubeye ulaşma minimum 72 metrekare
kullanım alanı olan iki tepeye göz
kamerası olan iki tane güzel 8 metrekare
tuvaleti olan çok güzel kahveler
krosanlar şunlar bunlar bilgisayarıyla
çalışan insanlar için de adam var
sıcaktan yorulmuş gelip oturmak isteyen
kitap okumak isteyen insanlar için de
alan var bu kafelerden hayal edin
geliyorsunuz ama Kapı kilitli
Çünkü kilit koyduk Kapıya bir tane
uygulama var cw uygulaması onu
indirmeniz lazım aylık cüzi bir üyelik
ücreti var ödüyorsunuz Ondan sonra
oradaki QR kodla içeri girdiniz artık
oraya girebilirsiniz
üyelikli ilk kafe zinciri içeri
girdiğiniz para geçmiyor her şeyi QR
kodla okutuyorsunuz böyle bir yer insan
odaklı çalışanlarımız her ülkede 2 tane
minimum asgari ücret alıyor artı Çiğdem
Hanım geldi 100 liralık alışveriş yaptı
tam ödeyecek 107 lira ödemek zorunda
çünkü yüzde 7 çalışan refah katkı payı
ekliyoruz Dolayısıyla Biz bütün
çalışanlarımızı net ciroya %7 ortak
ediyoruz Her cuma 18'de haftalıkları
bölünüyor Türkiye standartlarında 50000
şubeden sonra 60 bin lira civarında
gelir elde edecek insanlar
paylaşım modelinde de şehir lisanslama
modeline gidiyoruz ve ana şirket cüzi
bir oran alıyor %25 alıyor %75'i lokale
bırakıyor vizyonumuzda da hedefimiz
bizim 5.000 şehirde 50 binden fazla
tecrübeyi hızlı bir şekilde ulaşmak 5
yılda yapmak bunu detayları arasında bir
de dünyanın en büyük sanat galerisi
oluyoruz Çünkü her şubenin
dekorasyonunda maliyetlerden kısmak için
geçimini resim yaparak kazanan
sanatçılığın resimlerini alıyoruz
fiyatlandırıyoruz
tablolarımızı koyuyoruz
QR kodu var oturduk Bir arkadaşımıza
doğum günü hediyesi verdik baktık Bu kaç
lira 1750 lira Hemen okutuyoruz raftan
alıp götürüyoruz komisyon oranlarımız
çok düşük olacak dolaylı istihdamı
yaratmak adına proje ile ilgili daha bir
sürü Detay var bazıları şaşırabilir ya
İş fikrini böyle sahneden niye anlatıyor
aynı şeyi 2011'de yaptım İstanbul'da
2011 O scrini anlattığımda
Microsoft'un bir etkinliğindeydi her
şeyi anlattım çünkü yeter ki birisi
benden daha önce yapsın bizden daha önce
yapsın Çünkü insana değer katmak önemli
sloganımızdaki ağırlığı çok fazla oldu
Çok güzel dostlarla tanıştım çalışma
azmi arttırdı
saymakla bitmez birçoğu burada ve
belediye Fen Lisesi öğrencilerini de
düşününce burada Kadircan var onu
görüyorum
Çiğdem hanım da biraz sohbet ettik Bir
tane de şey yapalım o zaman cevap
opening
Fethiye Belediye fen lisesinden 2 tane
9 sınıf 2 tane 10 iki tane 11 2 tane 12
sınıftan toplam 8 öğrenciye Berk
neredesin el kaldır Berk benim asistanım
8 tane öğrenciyim projede
istihdam edelim onlara küçük bir maaşla
vereceğiz para da kazanacaklar projenin
değişik alanlarında hem girişimcilik
tecrübeleri artmış olsun
iş başvuruları Berke yapılıyor
minimum 1000 kelimeden oluşan bir tane
mektup yazacak arkadaşlar Berke
gönderecek onlar bana ve diğer
arkadaşlarıma gelecek mektupta serbest
kendilerini anlatabilirler vizyonlarını
anlatabilirler bin kelimeden az olan
mektupları almıyoruz Çünkü hayallerini
yazamayan insan gerçekleştiremez değil
mi
seminerlerde 300'den fazla seminerdi çok
fazla soru cevap vardı bir özet yapmak
istedim belki TED limitini geçiyoruz
yayınlanmayabilir çok önemli değil Ben o
soru ve cevapları özetlemek ve burada
bulunmamızın amacı hepimizin
enerjimizi yükseltmek daha iyi insanlar
olma yolunda güç kazanmak öğrenme
isteğimizi üretme isteğimizi
keskinleştirmek özellikle gençlerimizi
harekete geçirmek olduğu için küçük bir
özet yapıyorum Biz doğuyuz bizim
masallarımızda Alaaddin var lambadan bir
cin çıkacak bana diyecek dile benden ne
dilersen güzel
değişik sunumlarda da mitoz logosu
olarak anlatılırdı Bir de Batı var
ıssız bir ada Adamın biri adaya düşmüş
bir şey yapmak zorunda üretmek zorunda
klasik Instagram paylaşımlarında şey
vardır Dervişe sormuşlar maddiyat mı
önemli maneviyat mı der bir şey
sormuşlar sevmek mi önemli sevilmek mi
girişimciye ya da Ercan hocaya sormuşlar
hocam Hayal kurmak mı önemli çok
çalışmak mı Ercan Hoca ne diyecek git şu
kuşu bul Ona sor hangi kanalın daha
önemli diye böyle saçma soru mu olur
bizler zaman zaman sert Rüzgarlara
kapılabiliriz kuş da olsa savrulabiliriz
Ama denge çok önemli bir kelimedir
hayatımızda herhangi bir şeyin dengesi
olmadığı zaman Eninde sonunda Çok
yetenekli de olsak denge ve
tutarlılıktan yoksun her türlü
yeteneğimiz bizim başımıza bela açar
bizi Uyumsuz yapar bizi dengesiz yapar
hem sosyalleşme kısmımızda hem
yalnızlığımız kısmında bize sıkıntılar
yaratır yine öğrenci arkadaşların
girişimcilik yolculuğuna çıkan öğrenci
arkadaşların sorduğu sorular için böyle
kısa bir özet yaptım 7-3 benim için çok
önemli oldu Çok zor bir yolculuk Çünkü
bazen Kendinizden Hatta çoğu zaman hem
Kendinizden size güvenenlerden şüphe
ediyorsunuz bu kadar insan yanılıyor
olmaz diye O yüzden şöyle bir kural
gelişti 6-7 yıl önce 7/3 gün içinde 10
kişiyle vakit geçireceğim dikkat ettiğim
şey şu; 7 tanesi benim öğrenme isteğimi
artıracak Beni güldürecek bana iyi
şeyler hissettirecek pozitif enerjisi
olacak benim iyi insan olma iyi insan
kalma direncimi arttıracak özellikleri
olan insanlardan oluşmadı diğer üçü
istediği kadar negatif olabilir lanet
olabilir Onlar da var hayatımızda bazen
annemiz oluyor kardeşimiz oluyor böyle
bir şey bizim tolerans seviyemizi de
arttırıyor o klasik en çok vakit
geçirdiğiniz 5 kişinin ortalamasısınız
diyoruz ya
Bunu 100 yapalım bunu 500 yapalım Bazen
kopya çekiyordum Ama güne başlıyorum bir
lanet bir insan enerjisi yakınım ya da
uzak önemli değil 2 hemen orada
duruyorum telefona sarılıyorum enerjisi
güzel olan arkadaşlarımda 3-5 ile sohbet
ediyorum ondan sonra tekrar dengeyi
yakalıyorum 70'e 30 önemli bir kural
oldu hayatımda ilgi alanı etki alanı
ilgi alanı futbol maçı izliyorsan ilgi
alanına etki alanı çıkıp hareket
ediyorsan etki alanındasındır ona dikkat
ediyorum yüzde yetmişinde etki alanımda
kalmaya çalışıyorum
168 önemli bir rakam yine bir haftadaki
saat sayısıdır Bizler Yağmur
damlalarıyız Her insan Yağmur damlasıdır
doğru zamanda doğru iklimde doğru
şiddetle toprağa karıştığımız zaman
hayata Can veririz dünyanın
güzelleşmesinde önemli bir rol oynarız
nereye yağdığımız önemli değil sonuçta
nehirlere denizlere yeraltı sularına
kavuşuruz değişik formlara dönüşürüz
içme suyuna dönüşürüz ama aynı zamanda
Biz Yağmur damlalarıyız yanlış şiddette
bir yerde çok fazla yağmur damlası ile
buluştuğumuzda da sel oluruz yıkarız
mahvederiz o klasik atasözü hiçbir
Yağmur damlasını kendi hiçbir yağmur
damlası kendisini selden sorumlu
görmezmiş tam tersi farkındalığı idi biz
Yağmur damlasıyız dünyadaki her güzel
şeyden kendimizi güzel bir pay
biçmeliyiz Her kötü şeyden de kendimizi
acıklı olsa sorumlu hissetmeliyiz 168
benim için şey oldu bir saatle
başlamıştım ne yaparsam yapayım derdim
ne olursa olsun hafta benim için 167
saat bir saatinde bir kenara çekileceğim
benim dışımda Akrabalarım dışında
arkadaşlarım dışında Tanımadığım
bilmediğim ama dünyada bir sıkıntı
yaşayan sorun yaşayan insanların
dertleriyle dertleneceğim Sonra şuna
dönüştü dertlerle dertlenmek derdim
dermanımdır diye bir kitap yazma projesi
öyle Dertlerimiz olsun ki dermanımız
olsun bana iyi geldi haftada bir saat
bir kenara çekilip
düşünmek hiçbir şey yapamadığım
zamanlarda dua etmek evrene Allah'a
inancına göre artık çünkü gündemimize
aldığımız sorunları çözebiliyoruz Belki
bu benim için başlangıçta o ilk bir
saatler gündeme bazı şeyleri alma Evet
Mevlana'nın bir sözü çok seviyorum bb
sunucu ne Göremiyorum ben arkadan
söylesene
ve o b bilenler vardır biraz böyle
bekleyeyim bilmek başka bulmak başka
olmak başka niyetlerimizde çok iyiyiz
biliyoruz
buluyoruz da sonra yola çıkıyoruz ama
yolculuk Bazen çok zorlu oluyor
olma dönüşme değişme kendimizle baş etme
yolculuğun O yüzden Sabırla mücadele ile
ve etrafımızı güzel insanlarla
donatmayla yapıldığında bizleri
istediğimiz o dönüşüme götüren bir
yolculuk olabiliyor
İnstagramda paylaştığım şu aylığa
sunpetiye bu sampetiyi vizyonu için önce
Hazırlık yapmak lazım
Dolayısıyla ilk paylaştığımda
arkadaşlarım böyle bu ne anlamadık falan
filan diye hatta güzel bir şey duydum
biyografiyi gönderince San Fethiye diye
arama yapanlar olmuş hamfetti diye Acaba
bir mekan mı diye hayal
kurduklarımız olacak Bunun yıllar sonra
markalarımız olacak bir şeyler yapacağız
Fethiye markasını o I love New York
vardır ya görmüşüzdür Amerikan
filmlerinde Neden olmasın aylar Fethiye
ismi olur u ile yazılan olur o çok
önemli değil Bu da bizim sloganımız oldu
son olarak gelelim aaa'ya
Ben de dedim ki bu sunumun başlığı nedir
Muhammed nedir Mami nedir Mami bir
ağadır Halime nedir biradadır
Bade gelsene hep beraber yapalım sonra
yanımda dur kapanış yapıyoruz Gel gel
Evet Bade Bizim canımız ciğerimiz
kapanışı beraber yapıyoruz tamam böyle
sarıl Oh
Hepimiz bir a a ve a'yız 1 A
aktarılanlar
dünyaya geldik
yıllarca İnsanlar bir şeyler üretmiş her
forumda her biçimde inanç bilgiyi
tecrübe deneyim resim Sanat Müzik ve
aktarmışlar Bunlar aktarılanlar sonra
ikinci a
aktaran
aldıklarımızı
aktaran üçüncü ağa aktarıcılarız Bizler
Ercan abinin hikayesinde mutlaka
bakanlar olacaktır
aktarılanları birtakım filtrelerden
geçirdiğimizde
istediğimiz aktarıcı oluyoruz Çünkü
aktarılanlar çok fazla karanlıkta var
ışık da var İyi de var kötü de var güzel
de var çirkin de var Biz kendi
kodlarımızla zerafetimizle ledafetimizle
liyakatımızda adaletimiz de saygımızda
içselleştirdiğimiz her duygumuzla bir
sürü filtreler geliştirdiğimiz zaman
Dışarıdan aldığımız her şey istediği
kadar gelsin Çünkü içeride öyle bir
mekanizma kurduk ki ben nasıl bir
aktarıcı olacağım bu cümleyi tekrar
ederek bitirmek istiyorum ve unuttuğum
isimler olabilir herkese Şimdiden
teşekkür etmek istiyorum Bizler
aktarılanları aktaran aktarıcılarız
teşekkür ederiz
[Alkış]
[Müzik]